let's go next to steph from wisconsin
steph you're on the air well
hi david so um i actually had a question
kind of following up the person who
went before the spartanburg person okay
um
and it's about media literacy so do you
think it's possible to get to a level of
media literacy
that the majority of american people
would be able to watch something like
fox news and understand that
much of what they've reported on is
actually just opinions
i think yes because a majority just
means 51
and i think that's achievable i think
that's achievable i think that if you
said
80 you know if we got to sort of
propaganda
herd immunity for lack of a better term
where
enough people would understand that you
don't want to
signal boost fox news because then it
just spreads like a virus
i think 80 would be tough but yeah i
think we could definitely i mean listen
i think
35 to 40 of the country already gets it
so i don't think that it's unreasonable
to think we could get to it to majority
level yeah
okay and do you think um it's mainly
passed down like
i guess not passed down but is that is
media literacy primarily
um taught in schools or within families
social circles
i wish it were more taught in school but
unfortunately i think
that there are parents who vary
either explicitly but sometimes
implicitly
with other things teach kids to think
for themselves but also to understand
whether their beliefs are based on
something solid or something flimsy
and so i i think it would be great
if media literacy was actually being
learned and taught
in school more frequently unfortunately
i don't think it is and it really
depends on
on what's going on at home and
unfortunately what's going on at home is
not so good for a lot of people
and that's why i've been advocating that
media literacy and
and critical thinking and epistemology
would ideally start being taught at age
11
to everybody 10 11 12 somewhere in there
you think that late uh i mean i think
you can do things early you i think
earlier than that you can do you can do
things i think in third
fourth grade but it would have a little
bit of a different
flavor and tone i think they they would
be precursors
precursors but like real media literacy
probably you know
early middle school yeah from what i've
read
okay that's interesting yeah um one last
question
would producer pat start and only fans
okay well we will talk with what are you
looking to see on the only fans i guess
is the question i could
i could talk to him about it yeah ask
him about
maybe him doing hot yoga okay
uh all right steph very good we will
look into that and report back okay
perfect all right there's steph from
wisconsin very very interested in
uh the producer pat only fans content
all right that's too crazy a call so
let's take a quick break
we will regroup let things calm down
if you're holding don't hang up because
i'm going right back to the phones
momentarily